If you’ve ever wondered what it might take
to upset a microscopist, just ask James—our
master of microscopes—his feelings about
tardigrade legs.
Yes, tardigrade legs.
Those chunky, wiggly limbs
that move their owner
through meals of moss
and fields of debris.
What could possibly be in question when it
comes to tardigrade legs?
Why would such a seemingly mundane detail
of the invisible world around us become a
repeated point of contention in Journey to
the Microcosmos meetings?
The problem lies in the macroscopic world,
specifically in the myriad of stuffed tardigrade
toys available for purchase
and the fact that many of them
seem to have a fact-checking problem.
Take a moment right now to count the number
of legs you see on this tardigrade.
You should have hopefully counted four pairs,
making for a grand total of eight squirmy
limbs on our little water bear friend.
But unfortunately, many tardigrade toy manufacturers
seem to have stopped a little short in their counting.
While there are eight-legged tardigrades for
sale, you’ll also find plenty of spurious
ones that have only six legs.
So to this day, if the question of whether
we should produce our own Journey to the Microcosmos
tardigrade merchandise comes up—including
our t-shirts—James is the first to remind
us that it would be an opportunity to correct
the record in some small way.
Now if you have also spent your life thinking
of tardigrades as six-legged creatures, don’t
worry—we have made the same mistake and
have had to correct previous videos where
we described them as having six legs.
Now we’re not quite sure what it is about these
creatures that confuses their watchers in
this way, but we are all in good company
because the question of just how to count
tardigrade legs has been around since their
discovery.
And it’s not the only quality of tardigrades
that has inspired disagreement.
This creature has been confounding us for
centuries.
And while sometimes the scientific stakes
have been low, at other times,
they have been much much higher.
The tardigrade was first described by Johann
August Ephraim Goeze, a preacher in his 40s
who had only just begun his microscopy hobby.
But the beauty of the microcosmos is that
it can reveal itself to anyone willing to
look, regardless of experience.
And in 1773, Goeze would put the experience
of watching a tardigrade into words
for the first time.
He said,
Strange is this little creature, because the
whole organisation of his body is extraordinary
and strange and because his external appearance,
at the first sight, has the closest similarity
to a little bear.
Goeze called his strange creature “kleinen
Wasserbärs” or “little water bear,”
a name that has stuck as a nickname for the
tardigrade.
And about his little water bear—which he
also at times called a worm—he said,
The most remarkable feature of this little
worm are the eight short feet, each of which
is armed with three crooked and very sharp
claws.
But while Goeze’s publication was the first
to describe a tardigrade, it would not be
the only one for long.
Within a few years, three other scientists
would document their observations and inferences
on the unusual creatures found swimming around
in duckweeds and rain gutters.
Those scientists Johann Conrad Eichhorn,
Bonaventura Corti, and Lazzaro Spallanzani.
These papers were likely written independently
of one another.
And some of the features they described didn’t
line up—particularly the legs.
Eichhorn drew a figure with ten legs, though
we don’t know where he got ten from.
Meanwhile, Spallanzani described a creature
with six legs, though that seems to be due
to the fact that he considered the last pair
of tardigrade legs to not be legs at all,
but instead of a pair of hooked filaments.
Of course, a few mistakes here or there do not
prevent one from making important contributions
to our collective knowledge.
And one of the most lasting contributions
of Spallanzani was the fact that he called
these creatures “il tardigrado,” which
translates to “sluggard” or “slow walker.”
Of course, that name has since shifted into
what we now call “tardigrade.”
It’s not quite clear to us how the consensus
that tardigrades have eight legs was settled.
In 1785, a posthumous publication written
by the Danish naturalist Otto Friedrich Müller
established the correct number as eight.
And a translator of Spallanzani’s work—a
man named John Graham Dalyell—wrote in the
footnotes of his translation about a species
he’d found himself and named
Tardigradus Octopdalis, better known as
“the tardigrade with eight legs.”
So at some point, toy manufacturers aside,
there was an agreement that tardigrades have
eight legs.
Not six.
Not ten.
Eight.
It appears to have been a relatively low stakes
and low key argument in the world of tardigradology.
After all if you can just look at them and be like,
see, count, there's eight.
Then, it's fairly easy to settle the argument.
But not all arguments have been that way though.
In the middle of the 19th century, a 156 page
report was written by Pierre Paul Broca, a
French physician best known for his research
on the brain.
So why was Broca writing about an eight-legged,
slow-walking microscopic creature?
Well, he was there to settle an argument—an
old one—that gets to the core of tardigrades
and their remarkable capacity to survive.
Today, we know that water bears and many other
microscopic animals are able to survive extreme
conditions of heat or dryness by draining
themselves of water, desiccating into a husk
that essentially puts their life on pause
until conditions become tolerable again.
We know this process today as anhydrobiosis.
And it was first described in tardigrades
by Bonaventura Corti, who had observed rotifers
and other creatures going through it as well.
But as more scientists documented the anhydrobiosis
of tardigrades, more questions began to form
around just what anhydrobiosis was.
Was it death?
A state of pause?
To answer that, tardigradologists had to agree
on something even more fundamental:
could tardigrades and their fellow dried out
creatures live past anhydrobiosis?
After all, logic and experience suggest that
voiding oneself entirely of moisture is not
a sound survival strategy.
On the one hand, there were experiments carried
out by Spallanzani and others that seemed
to demonstrate the conditions necessary to
make anhydrobiosis a state that tardigrades
could resuscitate themselves from.
But others did not believe this kind of resurrection
was possible.
And in their quest to explain what others
were seeing, some very creative alternative
explanations popped up.
For example, the eminent naturalist Christian
Gottfried Ehrenberg believed that people
were actually seeing were the descendants
of the dried out animal emerging from the
husk of their great-great-grandparent.
And in 1859, this led to the involvement of
the Société de Biologie in Paris.
A commission was called to settle the debate
as presented by two French scientists.
On one side was Félix Archimède Pouchet,
who believed that tardigrades could not be
revived from anhydrobiosis.
On the other side was Louis Michel François
Doyère, who had documented his tardigrade
resurrection experiments in his dissertation
titled “Memoire sur les Tardigrades.”
I'm sure you're all so happy to hear my
French pronunciation.
Both sides documented their experiments, and
the commission performed control experiments,
resulting eventually in the report written
by Paul Broca that stated that Doyère was correct:
tardigrades that go through anhydrobiosis
can, in fact, be brought back to life from that state.
Of course, settling this debate only opened
the door for more—for questions that we are
still trying to answer about the mechanisms
that allow tardigrades to survive anhydrobiosis
and the limits to their resilience.
But that is the joy of science, the way that
disagreements compel us to strengthen our
own arguments, to seek out the tools and
experiments that will help us better understand
the world around us.
And perhaps, on that note, we should end with
something that we hope we can all agree on
as fellow hitchhikers through the microcosmos.
It’s a note from Goeze’s 1773 paper where
he first described the little water bears
that he had found.
Surely, there is no greater pleasure than
to see the polyps, the rotifers, and other
beasts of prey under the magnifying glass
seizing and swallowing their prey.
This can be achieved without traveling long
distances, without risking one’s life, and
without big costs.
A glass lens shows us a new world, and I know
from experience that you will be full of amazement,
when seeing that for the first time.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We love diving into history here on Journey
to the Microcosmos, but it’s important to
remember that “History” is not just the
same thing as the past.
The past is everything that has ever happened,
history is the curated story of all the important events.
But who gets to choose what’s “important”
and what influences that decision?
Well, “Study Hall: US history to 1865”
seeks to explore these questions as they cover
American History from the earliest Indigenous
groups to the Civil War.
So, if you’re sitting there, craving a bit
more history today, you can head on over to
youtube.com/studyhall or the link in the description
to watch “Study Hall: US history to 1865”
The people on the screen right now, they are
our patrons on Patreon, and we're so grateful
that they give us the opportunity to dive
deep and learn about not just what we know
now but how we came to know it.
That for me, is the most interesting and more
special thing about science.
Which is not, a body of information that just
appeared somewhere.
It is all stuff that human beings figured
out.
So thank you so much to all the people on
the screen right now, for helping us tell these stories.
If you want to see me from our
Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always subscribe button somewhere nearby.